wenn wir einmal einen Strich drunter
ziehen würden sie jetzt sagen
militärisch Putins Armee ist zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt deutlich geschwächt
gegenüber den Zeitpunkt vor einem Jahr
ja Putin glaubte die Ukraine im
Schnelldurchgang einnehmen zu können das
ist nicht gelungen weil die Ukrainer
stark dagegenhalten aber es wäre genauso
falsch zu glauben dass jetzt die
Ukrainer schnell siegen werden als gegen
these wir müssen uns auf einen
langfristigen militärischen Konflikt ein
aber deutlich schwächer als vor einem
Jahr werden sie absolut ich würde auch
sagen putin ist in der Rückhand und
deswegen ist der gefährlich und deswegen
ist eine neue Offensive zu erwarten und
würden Sie sagen das ist auch ihre unser
aller die westliche Leistung mit das
Putin heute wie sie sagen schwächer ist
seine Armee als vor einem Jahr es ist
beeindruckend Video keine kämpfte mit
welcher Intention und Motivation und es
ist auch die Geschlossenheit der
Europäischen Union und der NATO und auch
die Rückendeckung durch die Amerikaner
wie wie würden sie das Einschätzen ist
Putins Armee heute so dass man sagen
kann deutlich weniger Durchschlagskraft
als vor einem Jahr in diesem 24 februar
ist alles begann nein das würde ich ja
anders sehen die russische Armee hat
tatsächlich sehr viele Niederlagen
erleiden müssen nichtsdest zu weniger
mittlerweile gelang aus der russischen
Führung hier die
zu konsolidieren und sie steht wir
stehen kurz vor einer neuen Offensive
und äh ich würde tunlichste davon
abraten die russische Armee zu
unterschätzen warum die russische Armee
gelang oder russischen einige lange
sondern vergangenen Wochen doch
eindrucksvoll ist zu leisten
und ohne die westlichen
Waffenlieferungen wird das für die
Ukraine sehr schwer dagegen zu halten
und äh aus diesem Grund sind besonders
die kampfpanzerlieferungen sollten so
schnell wie möglich kommen noch bevor
der russischen jetzt reden wir nach fast
einem Jahr herangehen über den Zustand
über die Stärke der des Militärs von
Putin
ja wir können größtenteils nur
spekulieren wir können die Nachrichten
zusammensetzen wie in Puzzle welche
Informationen haben Sie aktuell über den
Zustand der russischen Armee ja ich
glaube das ist sehr schwer für
Außenstehende man hört sehr
unterschiedliche Sichtweisen und wenn
man im Internet das verfolgt dann gibt
es die Sendung wegesmeldung von beiden
Seiten ich wäre also da hier sehr
vorsichtig gibt es irgendwelche Quellen
den sie trauen
na ja wie sagte Bismarck nirgendwo wird
so viel gelogen wie während des Krieges
und nach der Jagd insoweit ist Vorsicht
geboten aber gleichwohl man sieht
natürlich im Augenblick ein Stillstand
man hat so den Eindruck dass auf der
einen Seite Quantität auf russischer
Seite gegen Qualität auf ukrainischer
Seite kämpft die Ukraine ist mit
modernen westlichen Technologien
ausgestattet wir reden immer über
Militärtechnik aber man muss auch die
Informationen sehen ich glaube das
westliche Nachrichtendienste zu liefern
und ein Teil der ukrainischen Erfolge
erklär relativ sicher auch aus dieser
engen Zusammenarbeit der
Nachrichtendienst mit Amerikaner mit
anderen westlichen Diensten ich glaube
das auch ein ganz entscheidender Faktor
jetzt haben wir gerade schon gehört Herr
Otto sagt na deutlich schwächer als vor
einigen Jahren widerspricht da vehement
wie würden Sie mit welchen Worten mit
welchen Adjektiven und mit den Zustand
von Putin am Meer beschreiben
ja ich glaube dass die Armee sich
reorganisiert hat am Anfang hat die
große Schwächen gezeigt
auf die ursprüngliche Planung
hingewiesen das war ja ein Blitzkrieg
dann hat man versucht den Norden zu
besetzen dann hat man sich auf den
Donnerstag konzentriert ich höre jetzt
aus Moskau und dass man die ganze
Ukraine einnehmen will ich habe Zweifel
ob das gelingt mit dem vorhandenen
Kräften ich glaube da müsste man die
russische Arme erheblich verstärken aber
die Entscheidung eine general Immobilie
machen und immer wieder erwartet wird
hat sich ja auch zumindest hingezogen
hat er hat sie nicht getroffen sie sagen
das jetzt so hören Sie aus Moskau was
sind das für Belege auf der Straße über
Geheimdienst Quellen also ich will nicht
über meine Quellen berichten aber ich
höre schon wie intern da überlegt wird
gedacht wird welche Kriegsziel verfolgt
werden ursprünglich die Enden
hatifizierung wie es immer schön hieß
jetzt setzt sich auch mal die Sichtweise
durch dass man die ganze Ukraine
angreifen will und wobei man Zweifel hat
jedenfalls ob dazu die Ressourcen
ausreichen dann müsste man
wahrscheinlich ganz anders antreten wir
haben eben schon gehört dass ein
Offensive geplant ist nur da fragt man
sich mit welchen Kräften die Ukraine ist
flächenmäßig eine der größten
europäischen Staaten wenn Sie die
Ukraine besetzen wollen dann brauchen
Sie wahrscheinlich eine Million Soldaten
die im Augenblick ist im Moment schwer
zu glauben können wir an dem Tisch
natürlich auch nicht wäre fixieren was
sie aus Moskau hören und was dann an
diesen Quellen tatsächlich dran ist
erfahrt wie ist wir haben über die
Informationslage in diesem Krieg
gesprochen und haben versucht
rauszufinden in welchem Zustand ist
Putins Armee welche Informationslage
haben Sie also ich meine ich gehe fest
davon aus dass die Russen immer noch die
militärische Eskalation Dominanz im
Operationsgebiet haben das heißt Sie
können nachschieben
Personal Material Waffensysteme sie
haben die logistische Basis direkt
hinter sich ähm und sie man kann sie da
letztlich nicht an die Wand drücken das
geht nicht auch unsere Waffenlieferung
auch die schweren Kampfpanzer auch die
14 deutschen Leopard 2 werden an dieser
militärischen Gesamtlage nichts ändern
und der amerikanische generalschaftchef
hat das ja mehrfacher zuletzten
Rammstein gesagt das ist sehr
unwahrscheinlich ist dass man das
militärisch drehen kann im Laufe des
Jahres und hat deswegen ja auch geraten
über andere Mittel und Wege nachzudenken
wie zum Beispiel politische
Verhandlungen sie haben am ersten
Kriegstag damals gesagt das wäre alles
nicht lange dauern voraussichtlich sie
haben genau gesagt militärisch gesehen
ist die Sache gelaufen meine Bewertung
ist dass es nur um ein paar Tage gehen
wird und nicht mehr sind sie froh dass
sie sich geirrt haben und dass diese
russische durchmachen nicht passiert ist
ja natürlich aber wir haben alle Anfang
des kriege ich kenne keinen Analysten
oder Experten der andere Meinung weil
wir haben alle geglaubt durch diese
schiere nur mehrere überlegenheiten der
Russen dieser schnelle Zugriff auf
kiefert funktioniert er nicht und dann
beginnt ja die Verlegung in den Osten
und dieses langsame vorgehen aber auch
erfolgreiche vor bin im dombas sind sie
froh dass es gehört haben
ja was heißt froh ich muss sagen ich
versuche immer Emotionen daraus zu
halten sondern die Lage so zu sehen wie
sie ist nicht und wir sind jetzt in
einem massiven abnutzungskrieg der
kostet jeden Tag uns Hunderte und
Tausende von Toten und
militärisch sehe ich nicht die
Möglichkeit das zu verändern einfach und
das treibt mich ein bisschen um wie
kommt man da raus und das ist ja das was
mag Miley auch sagt wo er dann sagt
Mensch denkt doch mal über politische
Lösungswege nach permanent wird drüber
nachgedacht einzig es bleibt im Moment
das Gebiet herzustellen von der Ukraine
und das will man will vor allen Dingen
die Ukraine will auch der Westen
logischerweise nicht erfahrt wir kommen
zu dem Punkt zurück wer noch einmal kurz
bleiben bei dem Punkt von Putins Armee
wir sehen Meldung oder hören Meldung
dass die Soldaten immer schlechter
ausgebildet sind man holt die aus dem
Knast die sind besoffen an der Front die
haben kaum Klamotten die kriegen kein
Essen das Material aus dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg und so weiter und so fort und
gleichzeitig ja du wo wie
werden Erfolge gefeiert von der
russischen Armee wie passt das zusammen
das sind natürlich begrenzte Erfolge und
die Mangelversorgung können wir hier
natürlich keinesfalls leugnen
nichtsdesto weniger kann Russlands die
mobil machen hier ausbauen denn die
genau immobilienmachung ist zwar nicht
befohlen worden aber so wie das
britische von Putin formuliert war
erlaubt dass einer der Faktor
mobil-agental mobil machen das heißt die
einzige Institution die über die Höhe
der Rekruten entscheidet ist das
Verteidigungsministerium ich wundere
mich nur ich wundere mich nur darüber es
werden mittlerweile recht moderne
Waffensysteme geliefert aus dem Westen
aus dem kompletten Westen im Grunde und
wir reden dann wir bekommen diese
Meldung über die Soldaten wie gesagt
schlecht ausgebildet keine Klamotten
schlechtes Material die Panzer aus dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg kann man dann sagen
Herr Otte die westlichen Waffenlieferung
waren bis heute in Erfolg wenn man es
nicht mehr schafft diese schlecht
ausgebildete Armee zurückzudrängen
auf jeden Fall notwendig ein Zeichen der
Solidarität zu setzen und sich am
militärischen Ziel der Ukraine zu
orientieren aber es erfolgreich nach
einem Jahr es war insofern erfolgreich
als dass die Ukraine durch Russland noch
nicht eingenommen werden konnte aber ich
will auch davor warnen zu glauben dass
man jetzt Russland unterschätzen könnte
denn sie können mit purer Masse mit
purer Quantität nachschieben mit
unbegrenzten Möglichkeiten und das macht
es so verdammt gefährlich also das
trauen sie auch der russischen Armee zu
sie trauen ihr eine beispielsweise
früher als Offensive zu auch noch mal
Angriff auf die Hauptstadt auf Kiel
spätestens im Frühjahr wenn ich sogar
jetzt wo die Böden gefroren sind und das
ist die große Sorge und deswegen sage
ich auch wir müssen wenn wir liefern und
das machen wir schneller liefern damit
man eher in die Situation gebracht wird
nämlich die Ukraine sich zu erwarten
noch einmal wie sie sagen beide da kommt
immer weiter Nachschub aus Russland
woher eigentlich woher nehmen die das
nun der Nachschub und Soldaten manchmal
kommt aus der Bevölkerung und an
Material Russland ist gerade dabei auf
Kriegswirtschaft umzustellen und sie
können diesen Schritt wesentlich
schneller vollziehen und nachhaltiger
als wir sie als könnten in unseren
demokratischen Gesellschaften und
zusätzlich hat Russland ja auch Partner
die ihnen Waffen liefern es ist
einerseits heran Russland Abkommen mit
dem Iran abgeschlossen über den Bau
iranische Drohnen in Russland und der
Russland kauft auch Munition von
Nordkorea ein sie sagen gerade viel
effizienter wie er
Brigadegeneral wie lange dauert das ein
Leopard zu bauen in Deutschland naja ich
habe mir sagen lassen also wenn man dort
die deutschen Rüstungsunternehmen auch
vor allen Dingen eins könnte sicherlich
100 Leopard 2 im Jahr bauen aber die
bräuchten eben auch eine gewisse
Vorlaufzeit um diese ganzen fertigen
stellungslinie zu bauen die Dokumente
und ja ich denke das geht nicht von
heute auf morgen nicht also
eben das heißt profitiert das heißt wir
bräuchten jetzt wir reden aktuell ja
über die Lieferung von Panzern die in
der Garage standen jetzt entstaubt
werden kampffähig gemacht werden und und
und wenn man jetzt Nachschub bräuchte
wir reden über den Nachschub auf der
russischen Seite würde das Jahre dauern
richtig naja wir haben ja wir hatten mal
vor kurzem also noch vor zwei drei
Jahren das hat mir mal der Schweizer
generadschaftchef scherzhaft gesagt wir
Schweizer haben mehr Kampfpanzer als ihr
einsatzbereit wir haben jetzt eine
Kampfpanzer Volumen von roundabout 300
Stück nicht davon essen was sind die
Hälfte oder 60% ist einsatzbereit mehr
nicht und davon geben wir eine ganze
Panzer Kompanie jetzt in die Ukraine
rein gleichzeitig sind wir möchten noch
mal festhalten Orte in der Produktion
langsamer und ineffizienter als Russland
ja weil in einer Autokratie kann anders
entschieden werden als in der privat
organisierten Rüstungswirtschaft aber
lassen nämlich sagenweise im Sommer
letzten Jahres hat der Deutsche
Bundestag mit breiter Mehrheit
beschlossen das schweres Gerät der auch
keine zur Verfügung gestellt wird und
jetzt haben wir gerade die Diskussion
hinter uns und der Kanzler hat mal alle
mal 14 Kampfpanzer zur Verfügung
gestellt das ist genau das Problem an
dem wir leiden das zu wenig und zu spät
bereitgestellt wird so oder so aber es
ist das entscheidend wenn wir jetzt über
Nachschub reden und das hat ja auch die
Bundesregierung angedeutet Herr Habeck
hat das ja in jedem Interview gesagt
dass es dabei natürlich nicht bleiben
wird dass die Panzer irgendwann auch
vernichtet sein würden oder man an
anderer Stelle eben Nachschub braucht
das heißt man muss sich darüber ja
Gedanken machen jetzt und wenn wir jetzt
hören von dem Fahrrad sie selber
bestätigen es dauert so lange ist das in
dem abnutzungsgegner verdammt schlechte
Nachricht also ich war eine vor einer
Euphorie derer die sagen jetzt gehen wir
mal dieses Fakten Gerät und jedes
waffengerät das müssen im übrigen die
Militärs entscheiden wir sind ja in
Deutschland eine Situation dass wir über
einzelne Waffensysteme diskutieren wir
müssen über Fähigkeiten reden orientiert
in der militärischen Strategie der
Ukraine aber dennoch muss früher
entschieden werden und es muss auch ein
Gesamt unterstützungskonzept geben für
die Ukraine wir Form von einem Tag in
den anderen und das ist das Recht nicht
wirklich der Unentschiedenheit der Ampel
zu verstanden was wir mit den oder der
ganze Westen mit den Waffenlieferungen
erreichen möchte in der Ukraine glaube
wir haben ja schon viel erreicht aber
wir haben erst mal erreicht dass die
Ukraine Widerstand leisten können und
zwar erfolgreich und zwar einmal mit
Waffensystem aber ich glaube auch was so
die Informationsversorgung betrifft was
eigentlich bei uns in der öffentlichen
Diskussion immer heruntergeht halte das
für ganz wichtig also ich glaube dass
das durchaus erfolgreich war aber
Russland hat erhebliche Ressourcen das
ist nicht zu unterschätzen auf der
anderen Seite wenn ich mir die
Ressourcen noch westlicher Seite
anschaue da würde ich dann nicht nur
alleine auf Produktion in Deutschland
abstellen sondern es gibt ja auch
panzerlieferung aus Großbritannien aus
den USA Evans wieder gehört haben ich
glaube nach wie vor vom Nachschub her
kann der Westen schon mithalten also
wenn ich sehe was über Polen zum Teil
auch über Rumänien geliefert wird das
ist schon ganz erheblich noch mithalten
wie noch mal auf diese Nachrichten
zerrissene Klamotten besoffene Soldaten
schlechtes Material und jetzt sagen Sie
nein nach einem Jahr der ganze Westen
die ganzen Nato-Partner da sind wir
schon in der Lage mitzuhalten was die
Material versorgen betrifft und ich
glaube die keine hätte ja nicht so
Widerstand leisten können ohne die ganz
erhebliche westliche Unterstützung das
muss ja deutlich sehen vor allen Dingen
aus den USA ich meine sind ja riesen
Pakete geschnürt worden und die Ukraine
war ja in der Lage überraschen für viele
für mich auch Widerstand zu leisten und
durchaus auch Erfolge zu erzielen das
muss man ja sehen die haben ja die
Hälfte des ursprüngliche eroberten
Gebietes zurückerobert auch das gehört
ja mit zum Kriegsgeschehen das heißt der
Krieg wäre wenn es die westlich
Waffenlieferung auch die deutschen
Waffenlieferung dann schließlich nicht
gegeben hätte möglicherweise vorbei ja
das glaube ich
sie haben enge Drähte auf beide Seiten
ich habe gerade schon gesagt sie haben
auch in Moskau studiert sie haben auch
eingetrete in die Ukraine wie würden sie
im Moment auf beiden Seiten die Stimmung
beschreiben wie groß ist die
Unterstützung für diese Operation für
diesen Krieg die Unterstützung in der
Ukraine ist nach wie vor sehr groß
natürlich muss der Präsident wurde
universellensky aktuell die Bevölkerung
für eine weitere mobil machen hier
startbereit machen und in Russland hohe
Verluste natürlich auf beiden Seiten
natürlich diese Verluste werden zwar
nicht immer kommuniziert offiziell aber
man versteht sie aus also Statistiken
sprechen z.B auf russischer Seite von
Toten pro Woche etwa halten Sie das für
realistisch ah durchaus ich glaube Mark
Milli hat sie ja im Dezember von weit
über 100000 toten Soldaten auf beiden
Seiten gesprochen hat zwar keine genauen
Zahlen genannt aber das wird es
wahrscheinlich ja vertreffen auf beiden
Seiten also etwa in der Balance oder
schätzen Sie die ukrainischen Opfer
deutlich höher ein
ich denke dass die
Opfer auf der russischen Seite durchaus
höher sein können
insbesondere auch aufgrund der Tatsache
dass wir so gut wie nicht gerne
nachweisbaren Daten aus Russland
bekommen
über die Verluste der Ukraine
wesentlichen Bescheid aber über die
Verluste Russlands eben nicht das heißt
während die ukrainische Gesellschaft
sehr wohl kampffähig ist und weiterhin
außerhalb ist die russische Gesellschaft
weitgehend innovativer fallen und lässt
diesen Krieg über sich einfach ergehen
das einzige Zeitpunkt wo der kriegt
tatsächlich in den Wohnzimmern der
Menschen angekommen ist war im September
vergangenen Jahres als die mobil machen
befohlen wurde und das war auch der
Zeitpunkt wo ist er kurzzeitig
vergleichsweise gefährlich für solche
geworden ist denn die Menschen sind
damals auch auf die Straße gegangen nie
also wenige in den Großstädten sondern
vor allem im nordgarten